[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur six ans par
les sports le premier numéro de la
saison sur tb 78 on ne change pas une
recette qui fonctionne l'émission est
toujours consacrée à l'actualité
sportive locale et nos chroniqueurs sont
avec nous pour décortiquer et analyser à
cette actualité
vu les conditions à solitaire certains
sont en plateau et d'autres via écran
interposé
présentation de la dream team en musique
on commence à ma droite il est en
plateau c'est le gladiateur de cette
émission et nous vient tout droit du
rugby-club de versailles on l'a d'or
vous l'adorez il sera encore avec nous
cette saison pierre chevallier nous fait
l'honneur d'être ici aujourd'hui
salut michael saluerait tous formats
bonheur comment allez vous ah bah écoute
très bien je suis ravi de retrouver les
petits camarades par certains à distance
d'autres en plateau on vit une drôle
d'époque est content d'être là on passe
de l'autre côté musique lui aussi est
avec moi en plateau c'est une grande
première pour lui sa toute première fois
les journalistes chez tv 78 il adore la
culture italienne et le sport c'est une
encyclopédie vivante
il aura sa rubrique dans cette émission
à chaque enregistrement l'italian lover
grégory canale est avec nous c'est chez
un gorille salue quand allez-vous très
bien très bien heureux de rejoindre
l'équipe la team si on parlait sport
heureux de sortir du cadre un peu
contraint et sérieux du jour là alors je
dis pas que ton et votre émission
je vais vous voyez quand même sur cette
émission n'est pas sérieuse mais voilà
content de parler de sport qui est l'une
de mes passions
voilà on a hâte de voir en tout cas
votre rubrique dans quelques instants
alors le saurons donc 3 en plateau les
autres sont avec nous via écran
interposé à cause du contexte sanitaire
je le disais précédemment musique c'est
notre spécialiste cyclisme mais il s'y
connaît dans tous les sports et les
licenciés au club de vélizy le capitaine
yann dujarrier est avec nous nouvelle
fois bonjour jan quand allez vous
bonsoir michael très très bien ça va
vous êtes bien installé chez vous
parfait est vraiment à billets comme
elle ils ont en tee shirt simple voilà
cette émission de toute façon c'est un
petit peu comme à la maison
alors l avantage est à la maison c'est
qu'en plus
anti sèches comme d'habitude j'ai tout
préparés et là en plus de les regarder
c'est parfait alors lui aussi est
connecté via écran interposé musique
c'est une légende de cette émission un
mythe il est aussi pertinent que drôle
vous allez passer un excellent moment
avec lui j'en suis persuadé coach genlis
est avec nous sur cette émission
bonjour connu un coup comment allez-vous
en mai super forme
super forme et puis super contents de me
revoir tout cela aussi c'est en vidéo
comme ça mais ça fait super plaisir de
vous en bois et voilà un bon jour est le
bienvenu à notre italienne de service
merci l'italienne glover grégory canal
est réputé italien gregorio copé corps
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler du tournoi de tennis de
plaisir qui s'est achevé ce dimanche 20
septembre coup de projecteur également
avec la coupe de france de football ça
sera la rubrique de grégory nous l'avons
baptisé l'envolée de grégory mais avant
de développer ces thèmes on va parler
cyclisme
on commence donc par du cyclisme
ambiance particulière à cette année sur
le tour de france 2020 au départ de la
21e et dernière étape à mantes-la-jolie
masque obligatoire pour les coureurs
journalistes à distance des cyclistes
pour les interviews un village départ
clairsemée du gel hydroalcoolique
distribués mais les passionnés ont fait
abstraction de cet environnement pour
profiter de l'événement organisé le
dimanche 20 septembre
on écoute les réactions on avait été
frustré de pas avoir de vélo pendant la
période du gros navires us et du
confinement donc un grand plaisir un
plaisir de l événement comme ça se
déroulait cette année l événement
un beau symbole pour nous d'être ici
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en plus de ça c'est bien
c'est les journées du patrimoine et le
tour de france fait partie de l'histoire
de la france
malgré ces conditions particulières le
public à lui pu voir la caravane les
coureurs et les stars de ce tour de
france pendant cette journée à
mantes-la-jolie notamment le vainqueur
de cette édition de semaine de 21 ans a
ledge paugam chars une fois les
présentations terminées les cyclistes
sont partis à côté du côté du val fourré
à mantes-la-jolie on écoute le président
du département des yvelines à pierre
bédier
c'est des moments les habitants ça
méritait qu'on se mobilise pour et c'est
inoubliable pour nous mais la question
sur cette thématique fallait-il organisé
ce tour de france cette année par
conséquent à mantes-la-jolie avec ce
contexte particulier vous votez oui ou
non
oui oui ou également pour vous gens vous
avez mis oui également vainqueurs alors
pourquoi alors moi je suis je suis pas
forcément le plus grand fan de cyclisme
comme comme chacun sait je ne je ne
maîtrise pas le sujet comme comme ian
mais sur le côté le côté purement
populaire de l'événement
comme le disait le
le spectateur interviewé sur le côté
patrimoine et côté mythique du tour de
france je trouve que c'était un très bon
remède contre la sinistrose ambiante
on sortait deux ans sortait de quatre
mois trois mois de confinement et quatre
mois de crise sanitaire et le tour de
france en france et dans le monde entier
et un est un passage obligé de chaque
année sportive notamment et je trouve
que malgré les malgré les gestes
barrière malgré les conditions une
condition imposée de masques et de et de
gels hydro-alcooliques
on a quand même pu voir les superbes
images tournées par les tournées par les
médias et la chaîne qui diffuse qui fut
au tour de france dans le monde entier
il y avait du monde sur les y avait
quand même malgré tout du monde sur les
chemins du bord des routes sur les
routes mais pas forcément n'a pas envie
l'état sur l'attentât sur le départ
alors c'est sûr qu'en termes d'animation
il ya moins de 7 ses alliés - de fait et
les moindres il ya moins de convivialité
mais on l'a vu notamment dimanche
dernier sur les routes des yvelines
jusqu'aux champs-elysées
il ya quand même pas mal de monde dans
le respect dans le respect justement des
gestes barrières et encore une fois cet
instinct est un remède est un antidote
contre la sinistrose c'était quand même
bien de le voir le voir rouler même en
septembre et même même pas forcément
juillet mais c'est un impératif sur une
saison au sporting il ya eu jane est
vous qui êtes notre spécialiste cyclisme
est ce qu il fallait forcément enfin
vous avez répondu oui il fallait
absolument organiser malgré le contexte
sanitaire du moment et bien sûr à partir
du moment où on arrive à mettre des des
protocoles qui permet de pouvoir faire
ville des manifestations sportives
quelle qu'elle soit parce que moi je
vais
je vais aussi voilà c'est génial que
roland garros puisse puisse commencer la
semaine la semaine prochaine ça fait
partie des grands monuments sportive
d'une année qui rythme nos années parfum
qui rythme la nema normal je viens
roland garros au printemps on sait que
voilà quand roland garros arrive il faut
aller voir le médecin pour prendre son
traitement anti pollen quand le tour de
france arrive on sait que bientôt on va
partir en vacances voilà il ya des
choses comme ça qui pour les sportifs
nous permettent de réguler à réguler
d'autres l'autre saison et autres années
bon bah cette année il y en a
quelques-uns qui ont été amputés c'est
vrai que moi j'ai passé un mois d'août
très morose parce que ben la voilà il y
avait il ya un truc qui devait se passer
cet été qui étaient des jeux les jeux
olympiques et c'est vrai que là il ment
il y avait un gros gros bang
donc voilà ça y est la rentrée est
arrivée le sport reprend reprend ses
droits
malheureusement encore au niveau amateur
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont qui
sont annulées et qui ne permettent pas
de de pouvoir pratiquer en compétition
alors que on a droit de faire des
entraînements voilà moi je voulais je
voulais que mes enfants puissent
participer comme comme tous les ans à la
compétition de la ronde pédestre de
vélizy et d'un malheureusement c'est
annulé alors que le bâlois c'est une
compétition tchéquie qui rassemble moins
de 5000 personnes faux pas voilà vous
faut être sérieux
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut mettre
cinq personnes dans un stade de foot
pour pouvoir suivre une suivre un match
de foot
et pourquoi est ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de
on n'a pas le droit de pouvoir
rassembler quelques sportifs qui veulent
qui veut se confronter et ils pouvoir
revivre normalement oui j'en je vais je
vais arrêter là dessus genre c'est à
vous alors les spectateurs étaient quand
même très loin quand même des coureurs
quand même sur ce tour de france
est-ce que ça pas enlever un petit peu
de magie peut-être sur ce thriller
france oui oui oui mais bon j'étais dans
une bulle 1 pendant toute la compétition
la crise sanitaire oblige mais quand
même on a vu on a pu voir quand même à
travers ce tour de france
l'engouement permanente du public sur le
sur la route du tour quoi et il ya eu du
jour est toujours énormément de monde
toujours énormément d'engouement sais
c'est vraiment la course populaire et la
plus belle course cyclisme du monde donc
et de glisse était obligé pour moi que
kay qu'elle est qu'elle ait lieu quoi et
là tout a été dit le reste ayant aidé en
leur servant de lp comme le meilleur
endroit pour pouvoir suivre le tour de
france c'est quand même quand on est
derrière son écran
oui en effet c'est sympa de temps en
temps de pouvoir avoir la chance d'aller
voir les coureurs autour de autour de
chez de chez soi ou passer devant chez
soi mais mais voilà là où vous voyez
mieux la course et soit sur la moto avec
thomas voeckler ou alors quand on est
quand on est derrière son écran avec les
superbes images qui sont faites par par
france tv et donc boire il faut il faut
en profiter la meilleure manière d'en
profiter c'est derrière l'écran après
oui bien sûr on ne peut pas aller
rencontrer les coureurs aux arrivées ou
dans les hôtels et ben c'est pas grave
mais le principal c'est la course après
ça me fait aussi des fans rien dujarrier
des fans qu'aux autres frustré également
par la situation ne pas pouvoir voir le
champion leur champion ouais enfin aussi
frustré de ne pas pouvoir aller au
cinéma normalement mais aussi piqué ne
pas pouvoir à nous rejoindre
aujourd'hui on vit une situation
sanitaire qui n'est pas normal je veux
dire tout à l'heure je suis allé je suis
allé à la poste et je suis obligée de
mettre un masque quand je vais à la
poste c'est pas normal
l'appareil le tour de france on peut
voir la course est bien quelque chose ou
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas tous vivre
de la même manière que dans l étude
vient pas le bourg de virus passera et
puis et puis et puis voilà
il mettra le temps qu'il faudra pour
passer et on retrouvera une vie normale
dans les les mois à venir
et puis et puis et puis c'est tout nice
est mauvaise c'est un mauvais passage à
passer mais moi je suis très content de
pouvoir revoir du est de pouvoir avoir
du sport à la télé très rapidement j'ai
adoré vous aussi vous êtes content de
revoir du sport tout à fait je rejoins
ce qui a été dit à une sino stries
sinistrose ambiante c'est vrai avec
l'annulation de grands événements et du
tour de france roland garros qui ont été
décalés l'euro de football et jo donc
c'est vrai qu'en tant que passionné
sport on avait envie de revoir vite des
compétitions oui le public c'est
l'essence même aussi du sport
professionnel dans les tribunes aussi
bien sur les routes du tour
mais voilà le tour de france ça a été
dit c'est un événement vraiment phare de
l'année c'est le troisième événement
sportif le plus regardé au monde
je crois que derrière devant enfin c'est
derrière les jeux les jeux olympiques et
la coupe du monde de football et puis si
les pas du tour de france cette année on
n'aurait peut-être pas vu aussi un petit
peu secoué historiques ces deux slovènes
un peu sorti de nulle part
paugam ça que vous l'avez rappelé je
vais y arriver je vais vous voyez dans
cette émission ça va être compliqué mais
peu get sa et le slovène le jeune
slovène qui est plus jeune vainqueur
depuis presque un siècle plus d'un
siècle même dans ce tour de france donc
on à tour historique
quoi qu'il arrive un jour historique
pendant l'été je pense un tour un tour
de force pour pourrait sauver les
différents organisateurs on l'a vu
d'ailleurs pendant le pendant la
l'organisation de la course mais sur la
course a également dans la caraïbe c'est
notre avance et surtout pour eux c'est
surtout à eux qu'il faut tirer le coup
de chapeau d'avoir réussi à monter à
monter ça on entendait d'ailleurs
christian prudhomme qui lui a été testé
positif qui est qui s'est retiré avec
qui revenu on l'a vu notamment
avantagées les dodgers de ne pas de ne
pas retirer ce qui crée du lien ça j'ai
retenu cette phrase là dans ce qu'il a
dit puisqu'il ya eu ces polémiques au
sulky à qui a surgi à lyon lors du
passage à lyon justement voilà cette
petite folie quand on va en parler
justement grégory ce que vous nous en
dire un peu plus sur cette polémique
oui alors c'est une polémique autour de
lyon elle vient de lyon on trouve autour
des propos du maire de lyon grégory
doucet un nouveau maire de lyon élu en
mars dernier europe ecologie les verts
il a jugé le tour machiste et polluants
dans un entretien accordé au journal le
progrès et a carrément menacé de ne plus
faire candidate et sa ville pour les
prochains tours de france on rappelle
que la 14e étape était arrivé à lyon
c'était le 12 septembre sur le côté
machiste
grégory de ça dit qu'il y aurait dû
avoir plutôt un tour féminin tour de
france féminin c'est un tour qui
existait auparavant qui a été supprimé
mais david lappartient le président de
l'uci l'union cycliste internationale a
dit que normalement on devrait y avoir
un tour féminin français à partir de
2022 donc ça devrait revenir à 6 les
propos qui ont fait forcément réagir
qu'ont suscité un tollé aussi bien au
niveau politique et sportif et viennent
s'ajouter d'autres propos sont aussi du
maire adjoint europe ecologie les verts
de paris qui a dit à lui carrément que
le tour de france c'était une
compétition avec des chômeurs qui
regardait depuis leur canapé des gens
dotés pour à la nokia série qui a eu pas
mal de polémiques autour cette
compétition on écoute justement la
réaction de pierre bédier le président
du département des yvelines supportable
il faut pas opposer les français et
français faut arrêter avec ce climat de
guerre civile
le tour c'est la france qu'on ne voit
pas c'est la france silencieuse c'est la
france absente des plateaux de
télévision
c'est ce qu'on appelait autrefois la
france profonde c'est aujourd'hui la
france silencieuse mais de moins en
moins silencieuse parce que ce mépris
permanent de certains est insupportable
chacun fait ce qu'il veut que dans les
métropoles certains maires considère
qu'il faut mettre en avant tel ou tel
politique c'est leur droit
il n'empêche pas du changement autant il
ne coûte pas 7e autre chose le tour
c'est un symbole de la france
jean est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
pierre bédier le tour ces symboles de la
france oui tout est dit rue est tout à
fait tout à fait légaux rila dit tout à
l'heure c'est la troisième compétition
la plus regardée dans le monde
c'est vrai c'est vraiment l'une des
grandes compétitions nationale populaire
si ce n'est la plus et donc à ce titre
là on n'est pas là on n'est pas là on
est là pour parler sport pas pour faire
la politique
mais à ce titre là quelle que soit la
personne qui vient critiquer ce genre
d'événement avec des décors de riz le
cocorico et éthiques je trouve ça
absolument ridicule parce que derrière
ça draine ça draine pas mal de de
bonheur et d'engouement encore une fois
de de pas mal de gens en 3d je voulais
juste ajouter parce que cette polémique
elle et elle est même venue en amour du
tour de france du haut des au
déplacement du départ 2021
donc qu'il devait avoir lieu au même
endroit où aura lieu la l'accord qui
s'appelle le championnat d'europe de
football
et donc il devait recevoir le deux
événements la ville devait recevoir deux
gros événements le même au même moment
et donc ce n'était pas possible donc le
maire a demandé un décalage en 2022 pour
le départ du tour de france et donc du
coup on a demandé à la bretagne
d'accueillir le départ du tour de france
2021 et et il ya une écologiste de raids
qui avait déjà émis ces mêmes ces mêmes
critiques par rapport par rapport au
tour de france en disant qu'il s'était
pas c'était pas écolo jeu en effet c'est
vrai qu'il ya une caravane et il ya des
choses qui se déplacent autour des
cyclistes mais il faut pas non plus
oublier que le cyclisme sur les abris à
une centaine de véhicules dans la
caravane cette année il y avait une
centaine de véhicules
oui bien sûr mais il ya des véhicules en
amont il ya des véhicules an après après
les après les cyclistes donc oui bien
sûr que ça déplacé sa développe du co2
mais faut pas oublier que c'est quand
même pour faire la promotion d'un sport
propre
voilà et quand même un sport qui est
l'outil que beaucoup de gens l'utilisent
au quotidien pour pouvoir se déplacer
alors pouvoir aller au travail etc
donc c'est aussi la promotion d'un du
vélo n'était pas seulement une épreuve
sportive
donc voilà il ya aussi un moment où faut
arrêter d'avoir des oeillères et ouvrir
un petit peu ses chakras les deux
druides druid les deux maires de droid
pro de véhicule à boîte électrique et il
faudra course à pied qu'est-ce qu'il ya
de nouveaux horizons ça vous met très en
colère cette histoire et jean cette
émission c'est si on parlait sport si on
fait une toute petite parenthèse
politique puisque on est les deux pieds
dedans je pense que ça procès beaucoup
plus de l'effet d'annoncé de nouveaux
modes et de maire nouvellement élus et
de leurs adjoints au même titre que la
suppression du sapin de noël sur la sur
la mairie de bordeaux
c'est c'est assez malvenu ça fait parler
ça fait le buzz dans un contexte déjà
très particulier où parler de sinistrose
et on parle justement moindre un peu en
berne
on maintient coûte que coûte un
événement avec les mesures adaptées
n'allons pas n'allons pas justement m
mettre tout ça par terre avec simplement
des des petits procès clientéliste qui
ramène simplement la lumière assoit sur
sur des faux procès parce que parce que
le tour de france ça reste ce monument
là est la meilleure réponse est celle de
christian prudhomme qui dit surtout ne
cassons pas ce qui fait que ce qui fait
le lien entre les français quelle que
soit leur valeur leur avis quel que soit
leur bord politique et quelle que soit
l'heure lors leur goût pour le cyclisme
ou pour d'autres sports là en
l'occurrence et s était la meilleure à
tous ce sera le mot de la fin sur cette
thématique pierre chevallier ont
continué cette page coup de projecteur
par le tournoi de tennis de plaisir la
finale du tournoi future de tennis a
tenu toutes ses promesses après un
premier acte serré c'est le néerlandais
igor sijsling 310e mondiale qui remporte
le set 7 6 face aux français yoann tacle
aux 500 12e mondial le deuxième set est
remporté par le tricolore 6 3 mais c'est
finalement le joueur d'amsterdam qui
remporte le tournoi 7 6 dans le dernier
set en 2h45 de jeu on écoute la réaction
du vainqueur je suis très heureux ce fut
un match difficile
c'est un joueur très jeune qui joue très
bien on était vraiment proche sur cette
rencontre
chaque point était serré seulement
quelques points ont décidé de ce match
je suis très heureux à propos de ça une
réaction pour chevalier peut-être sur ce
tournoi de plaisir encore du sport
encore du sport que l'on voit grâce à
vous grâce à vos services ont convoi à
l'antenne il faut pas oublier que le
le calendrier de tous les sportifs tous
sports confondus a été complètement
chamboulée
cette saison là y compris pour les
spectateurs que nous sommes et les
amateurs de sport que nous sommes donc
là je pense un tournoi qui porte très
bien son nom parce que c'est donc sur
l'aspect futur quelques quelques
semaines avant finalement l'organisation
de roland garros qui on l'a rappelé
heureusement se tient également en
septembre
là en ce moment les qualifications et
puis le tournoi qui démarre la semaine
prochaine donc une malgré tout une bonne
exposition également pour la ville de
plaisir et le département toujours un
beau d'un beau tournoi dont il est dont
il est agréable de parler à nouveau sur
ses antennes ces ajustements se
poursuivent la vie quotidienne ça ça
passe par les activités tous les jours
ça passe aussi par les événements
sportifs oui il ya un cadre contraint un
cadre sanitaire maintenant il faut aussi
apprendre à vivre avec le virus avec des
mesures effectivement sanitaires à faire
respecter mais on est bien content que
ça reprenne en tout cas dans un cadre on
va dire à peu près normal et ce tournoi
justement de gorée a failli ne pas se
jouer
oui parce que donc on le rappelle c'est
cet événement c'est troisième la
troisième plus grosse compétition de
tennis en ile-de-france derrière roland
garros et le tournoi de bercy il a
failli ne pas se disputer à cause du coc
u19 les organisateurs ont décidé tout de
même de maintenir ce tournoi avec des
conditions sanitaires drastiques y avait
32 joueurs dans le plateau final
contrôle de température corporelle à
l'entrée du site port du masque
obligatoire al aqsa l'extérieur des
courts mise à disposition aussi de gel
hydro alcoolique il ya eu aussi un
aménagement de zones de rencontre ouvre
là pour on va dire cadenassé un peu tout
ça on écoute justement le président de
la ligue des yvelines
au niveau national il y avait très peu
de tournois justement professionnels
notamment ses premiers tournois futures
ou les joueurs les jeunes joueurs
professionnels chercher à avoir des
points il y avait pratiquement est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure lors de la
remise des prix c'est que je préside en
charge de l'anneau a eu le courage on
vraiment d'organiser le tournoi
la question sur ce thème l'organisation
de ce tournoi t-il at elle fait du bien
aux sports yves binois je me dis que
vous avez répondu oui non pas forcément
pour bouyahia dujarrier vous avez mis un
petit peu de temps avant de dégoupiller
après après c'est ce que c'est
exactement ça revient à tout ce qu'on
disait juste avant c'est que tout
événement qui va pouvoir avoir lieu
prochainement ben tant mieux tant mieux
pour pour tous
maintenant oui comme deezer com et
grégory on a des idées des conditions
particulières il faut il faut s'adapter
il faut il faut prendre faut faire avec
ce qu'on nous demande de faire et puis
et puis c'est tout et il faut faire le
dos rond ça va passer et puis et puis
voilà mes billets armin allemand aux
sports yves binois l'organisation de ce
tournoi mais ça montre que l'on peut
continuer de faire du sport mais voilà
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
c'est dommage que une course la ronde
pds de vélizy qui kiffent un mois tient
à coeur puisque c'est c'est la ville la
ville que leur présentent de très très
souvent et donc
donc voilà je trouve ça dommage que que
ben on ne puisse pas aller faire de la
course à pied alors que voilà ça fait
des ça fait des mois et des mois que
tout le monde peut le reprendre
ça fait des mois qu'on peut reprendre
l'entraînement et même pendant
confinement on a autorisé des gens à
pouvoir courir une heure par jour
et puis là maintenant on est des confiné
et on ne peut plus on ne peut pas se
confronter les uns aux autres donc et
après oui je peux comprendre que un
marathon de paris quarante mille
personnes qui viennent de tous deux de
partout dans le monde
oui que ce type d'événement soient
contraints à des restrictions et ne
puisse pas avoir lieu
mais des petites courses régionales
voire départementale
là j'ai beaucoup plus de mal quoi quand
est ce qu'on va pouvoir revivre
normalement c'est le fait d'avoir ce
type 2
d'événements qui est qui qui peuvent
avoir eu lieu donnent l'impression que
voilà on pourrait vivre vivre
normalement il a joué à pas grand chose
c'est des petites choses mais oui on
arrête mais par contre voilà le problème
qu'il y assez que dans tous les journaux
au quotidien on nous dit il y a des
nouveaux kloster par-ci par-là
grand-peine dentelle on avait encore
faire un peu politique un médecin voilà
on parle que de ça en ce moment partout
où on va mais voilà vous avez encore eu
un ehpad où il ya eu des cas vous avez
encore un cluster à droite daniel g
jarrier il faut garder de tennis ces
personnes qui se voulait positif il ya
déjà rien valoir les tennis ouais il
faut parler tennis mais donc voilà pour
moi cet événement pour cet événement là
nous permet de penser que oui on va
retrouvé un une façon de vivre qui sera
qui sera normal et tant mieux pour le
tennis tant mieux en plus de dire le
tennis c'est pareil c'est quand même un
sport où les mecs qui se croisent n'aime
pas et chacun joue à plus d'un mètre
l'inde hôte donc allez-y faites du
tennis fait du golf il lancé vous il est
tous les jouets voix genre j'ai une
ressort message numéro de l'yonne
il déplore que le tournoi était pas lui
deux coloristes est venu avec sa voiture
incroyable jean sérieusement est-ce que
ça vous a fait du bien de voir un
événement comme celui-là organisé résume
bien sûr et bien sûr en bleu à deux mais
bien sûr c'est au moins au moins sur le
haut mais de france de golf par exemple
a été annulé un événement qui regroupe
j'ai énormément de monde chaque année et
également l'éco trail qui a été annulé
aussi récemment qui devait se disputer
en octobre qui ramène également
énormément de monde
il y a également les petits ni conseil
algérien n'a parlé précédemment qui ont
été annulés
finalement c'est le premier gros
évènement dans les yvelines qui a été
autorisé oui mais ensuite et organise
une responsabilité et aujourd'hui les
organisateurs prennent ou pas la
responsabilité d'organiser donc
il ya ce gain de ce phénomène si vous
organisez une compétition à à plus ou
moins une grosse échéance fait oui
échéance et fille avec beaucoup de
participants mais vous prenez le risque
qui vous arrive qui vous arrive est un
petit peuple est donc aujourd'hui elle a
qui prennent ce risque et qui endosse la
responsabilité et qui fondent les
organisations telles que ce tournoi de
tennis higuain bourg il rappelé et bien
galerie de l'oxer dit qu'elle aimait
bravo moi je dis bravo parce
qu'aujourd'hui et il faut il faut
reprendre essayer de reprendre une vie
sportive normal avec bien sûr des gestes
barrières c'est le mot le mot clé là où
on peut se s'estimer peut-être les plus
chanceux c'est dans le sport amateur
là on part on parle beaucoup
d'événements professionnels du sport
professionnel avec heureusement quelques
affiches qui se tiennent quelles que
soient les sports dans le sport amateur
en fait je pense que tout le monde fait
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur il
s'adapte à la situation malgré tout il
ya d'autres événements dans les yvelines
et dans tous les sports avec justement
un protocole très strictement appliquée
par exemple en exemple que je connais
bien ce dimanche à porsche fontaine le
rugby-club versailles reçoit pour la
première fois et à chaque fois c'est
avec les prises de température
le tracé et le tracé le traçage des
spectateurs qui viennent qui viennent
assister au match masque obligatoire
gels hydroalcooliques et ça passe comme
ça au moins au moins on assiste à du
sport amateur mais on assistait du sport
je trouve au football c'est pareil un
masque obligatoire dans les vestiaires
on reprend le championnat ce week-end
jusqu'à la mise en place sur le terrain
avec le jouet josas voilà je les salue
d'ailleurs les admissions en josas mais
pareil l'entraîneur qui prend les noms
pour un éventuel traçage si un cas
positif de colis 19 donc on peut
s'adapter mais il faut continuer tous
deux mènent aux sports dernière question
sur cette thématique est ce que
l'organisation de ce tournoi très
rapidement a permis à peut-être un
tournoi comme roland-garros de se jauger
un petit peu ou pas du tout grégory
alors oui ça montre que même un niveau
local on peut organiser effectivement ce
genre d'événement après je pense que les
deux événements
on pas très comparable roland garros lui
moi je me suis notiez quelques chiffres
c'est en 2019 ses 186 personnes qui
étaient en charge de l'entretien des
courts 263 ramasseur de balles
trois cent vingt arbitres 480 me plus de
480 mille spectateurs 150 mille
sandwiches vendus
voilà on est sur un tournage d'une autre
dimension après ça prouve que même avec
des structures on va dire un peu plus
petit niveau local on peut organiser ce
genre d'événement donc oui c'est de
bonne augure en tout cas pour le début
de roland garros la semaine prochaine
pierre vous êtes d'accord
je suis d'accord et ça et d'ailleurs ça
coïncide avec la fin des travaux
d'adaptation de notamment du court
philippe chatrier du central de roland
garros avec un toit couvert parce qu'il
y avait ce risque là vous me direz
depuis depuis maintenant quatre ou cinq
ans il pleut à chaque fois au mois de
juin et s'est imposé ça n'a pas été sans
poser un grand nombre de problèmes
l'organisation là ça coïncide avec se
maintenant sur trois autres acteurs
rétractable sur le central ça devrait
permettre de jouer même même jusqu'à
début octobre pour la dernière semaine
du tournoi
donc on a une première piqûre de rappel
déjà aussi pour l'engouement et puis le
l'envi d'assister à du sport
professionnel et roland garros qui était
plutôt un mastodonte qui arrive derrière
avec avec justement cette cette
exposition internationale
et là aussi ça va faire du bien à tous
ceux qui pourront y aller peut-être la
météo sera meilleure qu'en mai et en
juin 7h dernièrement sur les dernières
années presque émouvant lors de la ryder
cup 2018 de 50 ans j'habite un temps
exceptionnel on passe maintenant notre
page débats
[Musique]
on continue par du football est votre
rubrique grégory nous l'avons baptisé
leurs volets de grégory de quoi allez
vous nous parler dans cette envolée
j'ai envie de commencer par une question
un petit tour de table et aussi avec ian
et les gens qui sont avec nos envies ou
est-ce que si je vous dis linas
montlhéry ça vous évoque quelque chose
je le vois avec l as marcoussis et
ouais petit petite équipe qui va loin ou
qui ira long tout à fait jean et yann ça
vous dit quelque chose
oui ils sont un groupe de phrase alors
c'est lnr effectivement c'est le nom de
cette valeureuse équipe estonienne qui
s'est hissé jusqu'à jusqu'au 32e de
finale de la coupe de france la saison
passée en face il y avait le paris saint
germain et ses stars alors pas tout les
storm il y avait tout de même sur le
terrain cavani draxler kurzawa ou encore
sarah bien cinq divisions d'écart entre
les deux clubs d'un score fleuve 6 à 0
pour les parisiens mais la victoire
était tailleur une ambiance de fou dans
les tribunes 15000 supporters avec
notamment l les ultras du paris saint
germain une énorme médiatisation autour
de l'équipe francilienne et des
souvenirs plein la tête pour ces joueurs
amateurs qui pourront raconter sur
plusieurs générations alors oui cette
saison au vu du contexte on ne reverra
pas autant de supporters dans les
tribunes mais j'ai envie de vibrer cette
saison pour une équipe yvelinoise
qu'elle fasse à un parcours un petit
poucet bilan un parcours comparable
face à de grandes équipes en coupe de
france alors quel club pourrait réaliser
pareil parcours à votre avis on pense
forcément à versailles d'ailleurs la
saison passée les joueurs de la cité
royale sont arrivés au barça il faut que
les par versailles rugby mais je vais
parler un petit peu de rugby
vous allez voir la pierre plus que
versailles l'année dernière ils se sont
aussi hissé jusqu'au 32e de finale de la
coupe de france
l'affiché était certes intéressante mais
un peu moins clinquante c'était
granville en face les normands
pensionnaire de nationale 2 soit deux
divisions d'écart
or c'est surtout sur le scénario du
match qu'on peut être déçu versailles
avait ouvert le score avant de
s'incliner 2 buts à 1 et sur nous et
surtout granville avait affronté au tour
suivant une équipe que vous connaissez
bien nickel c'est l'olympique de
marseille
on est peut-être passé à côté d'une
grande affiche malheureusement tout à
fait alors lancée de l'année d'avant
versailles avait effectivement affronter
le rc lens fin 2018 au 8e tour de la
compétition
le légendaire rc lens son kop aussi ce
champ des corons que l'on connaît pour
l'occasion d'ailleurs les ultras du
rugby-club de versailles s'était joint
aux fans de foot quoi le rugby le
football ne sont pas si loin de clients
mais bien sûr qu'on sait dans la même
ville bien sûr c'est pour nous il y
avait eu voilà beaucoup de supporters
dans les tribunes une ambiance aussi de
dingue
le fcv avait fait jeu égal avec les
lensois avant de s'incliner 4 buts à 2
il ya aussi voici avec laurent fournier
sur le banc clément chantôme poissy qui
est dans une mauvaise passe en ce moment
mais la coupe de france pourquoi pas ça
pourrait être une bouffée d'oxygène pour
les pisciacais souvent ce qu'on dit
quand une équipe est mal en championnat
elle va loin en coupe de france ils sont
souvent des des beaux parcours alors il
ya les mureaux également qui évolue en
nationale 3 ce ne sera en revanche pas
le cas pour le fc mantois qui s'est fait
sortir au troisième tour le fc mantois
rappelez-vous en 2016 il les a va
affronter le fc nantes en 16e de finale
une défaite 1 à 0
ou pourquoi pas carrément me caler alors
là je me projette voilà je suis
enthousiaste un club de niveau
régionaliste et optimisme trappe
conflent ou encore trappe voilà mais je
les ai déjà dit je crois au quatrième
tour ils seront bien au 4e tour de la
coupe de france
les espoirs sont permis quand on sait
que linas montlhéry avait été en
régionale 1 donc c'est aussi une équipe
régionale
voilà j'ai envie de voir cette saison
mickaël un petit poucet évinois arrivé
loin dans cette coupe de france est une
compétition où les rêves sont permis
on a vu par exemple l'équipe de quevilly
ou encore calais en 2000 qui était
arrivé les amateurs au stade de france
en finale de cette coupe de france est
en ces temps difficiles on a besoin
d'une belle histoire au club yves inward
et emmène de nous la raconter est ce que
c'est possible c'est la question sur
cette thématique est ce que vous ce que
l'envolée de grégory possible cette
saison
oui ou non voter non à ont fait un petit
duel entre vous pierre spierer mégane
ianu commencé j'ai pas dit non non c'est
ça à g
moi j'ai dit ça joker alors a de toute
façon bien sûr ça fait des années en
plus que j'en parle à chaque fois qu'on
est sur le plateau et je me souviens
très bien de versailles qui avait un
végétal et perdu contre granville et
granville rencontré rencontrer l'om
juste derrière
et voilà je l'avais dit ils sont passés
juste à côté de la halle aux chaussures
et en effet on rêve tous et on leur
souhaite en plus on leur souhaite de
pouvoir vivre ces événements
moi j'avais fait le parallèle avec des
avec des compétitions où j'ai que j'ai
pu faire où il ya des 2500 personnes
dans le vélodrome de saint quentin et on
sait que 2500 personnes dont de nombreux
tracés beaucoup puisqu'il est rarement
plein qui se met des mots voilà c'est
vrai que je pour pour du vélo grèce à bb
b par contre voilà c'est vrai que c'est
des événements qu'il faut aller chercher
parce que en effet c'est pas quand on
est au cinquième tour que non c'est tous
les tours il faut les jouer à fond c'est
pas c'est pas les dix ans dix ans mais
au prononcé chaque tour qui va vous i am
et est en effet il faut se battre et il
faut les il faut les préparer de la
meilleure manière possible
il y à une ambiance sur cette coupe de
france il ya cette possibilité
moi je ne conçois pas de faire du sport
sans vivre ces événements si j'ai la
possibilité de le faire je vais donner
tous les moyens et donc je pense que nos
ça se produit quasiment tous les ans des
petits poucet qui arrive à faire des
belles histoires et des mails rencontre
n'est pas forcément il faut un nouveau
mais non non j'ai bien dit ça arrive
tous les ans en france voilà donc bien
sûr carquefou carquefou pour les
supporters marseillais aussi à leurs
souvenirs
par exemple donc voilà c'est c'est des
choses qui sont possibles c'est des
choses qui qu'il faut le garder dans un
coin de sa tête et et et ses joueurs
qu'ils en or ils ont sortiront une
expérience qui sera inoubliable
ils s'en souviendront toute leur vie de
d'avoir vécu ces moments et donc moi je
leur souhaite
battez vous pour ça
préparez vous à fond pour ces matches et
voilà cette année on a pas mal de
personnes aux quatre coins de clubs au
quatrième tour on sait que c'est les
tours qui commença à une durée je me
souviens que l'année dernière mais ça
c'était 6e ou 7e tour on avait plus que
deux représentants et ça n'avait pas été
sa vait pas été au-delà donc voilà il
faut il il faut que ce soit une fonction
à une motivation et en plus je dirais
que c'est peut-être cette année avec
c'est avec ces conditions très
particulières qui qui seront encore peut
être plus favorable aux petits optique
le voilà genre est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
est-ce qu'on veut voir un club génois
aller loin cette année
oui bien sûr bien sûr ce c'est notre
souhait à tous et l'avantagent biya sait
que cette compétition ce sport le
football en a parlé plusieurs fois sur
le plateau ce sport et cette compétition
particulièrement permet justement à ces
petites équipes sur le papier bien sûr
puisque elles sont pas si petit que ça
et ça permet quand même chaque année de
découvrir un petit club entre guillemets
j'aime pas trop le terme petit club mais
les divisions sont là qu'un pour faire
les la différence des niveaux et il ya
toujours toujours tous les ans le petit
poucet pour une la peine de friends et
donc pourquoi pas cette année un club
yvelinois
ce serait ce serait génial encore une
fois cette compétition le permet car
chevalier premièrement c'est la première
envolée grégory donc on va aller on va
souhaiter que ce soit un porte bonheur
pour les pour les copies finnois
ressortir à la bombe
pour l'instant il ya six clubs qualifiés
pour le 4e prix excellent et binoy plus
deux autres qui vont rentrer ça sera
poissy versailles sera dépassée porter
la poisse à versailles je les ai suivis
deux fois sur les matches à chaque fois
ils avaient peur de mélanger en plateau
droite
vous ne bougez pas la deuxième c'est que
comme comme héroïne j'ai envie de rêver
sur cette magie de la coupe
jean l'a rappelé il ya nos six essais
c'est une compétition unique
au rugby on avait la chance il ya
quelques années des tanks jean et moi
avons connu mais que les moins de 20 ans
non d'avoir le challenge yves du manoir
gens qui étaient ici qui était aussi une
opposition de plus petit club de plus
petite division pas dire petits clubs et
deux clubs professionnels notamment
aussi donc c'est sa justesse ce brassage
fantastique du sport amateur et du sport
professionnel mérite mérite des mises en
avant permanente chaque fois il nous
fait nous fait nous fait le coup du
petit poucet les clubs l'illinois ils
sont assez nombreux ils sont de mieux en
mieux depuis
depuis depuis des années et notamment
versailles grégory l'a rappelé sur le
sur le palmarès de la coupe du monde de
la coupe de france par leur pressant et
qui est leur coupe du monde à eux qui
est là taylor saison ça fait vraiment ça
fait ça fait 2 2 lièvres à courir à la
fois est certain qu'ils vont moins bien
en championnat vont bien en coupe
donc oui on peut on peut clairement
clairement l'espérer le souhaitait
ardemment surtout dans cnp rapidement
très rapidement la coupe de france ça
peut servir aussi pour le championnat
versailles est monté alors oui le
championnat est arrêté avant mais
versailles a fait un beau parcours les
nerfs 32e de finale certes ce n'était
pas contre le paris saint germain mais
ils sont montés derrière en nationale 3
et linas montlhéry qu'il y en a deux en
nationale 2 et nationale 3 à son
international deux essais montlhéry le
club de linas montlhéry qui a joué ce
32e contre le paris saint germain qui
eux ont été promues en nationale 3 or le
coup voilà la fin de la saison
alors on continue ceux ci ont parlé
sport par une performance à seulement 21
ans thomas d'eric a déjà réalisé
plusieurs défis dont une marche de 140
km 1 vézère de sel en bolivie c'est et
il a réussi à traverser avec sa copine
justin andres la france du nord au sud
en roller et oui vous avez bien entendu
les partis le 18 juin dernier de l'île
pour arriver le 25 août dernier à la
frontière espagnole
on écoute thomas d'eric nous l'avons
rencontré à son retour c'est un moyen de
déplacement assez originale j'ai presque
jamais vu d' aventure faite en rollers
donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas essayer
et je trouve qu'elle est plus lentement
au rythme des roulettes
une manière de découvrir le c'est une
bonne alternative en fait entre le vélo
et la marche on voit la c1 c'est pour
ces raisons là alors mais cette
performance n'a pas été de tout repos il
ya eu notamment une chute de sa copine
justin andres au début de leur périple
il est également une chute de thomas
d'eric on la regarde justement j'ai plus
peur
[Musique]
très attaché
freins il s'est envolé en fait grégory
d'une réaction m'a déjà que quand je
pense que ce n'est pas drôle ça fait mal
la brûlure du terrain synthétique là
j'imagine même pas sur le bitume
ça doit être douloureux pierre deyries
qui porte bien son nom c'est ce que je
me souviens delà de toutes les séquences
qu'on a fait sur son premier exploit de
traversée d'un désert de sel
je trouve que c'est un personnage
extrêmement original qui se fixent des
défis là tout aussi originaux puisque à
priori ça a l'air d'être le seul à
s'être attaqué à ce genre de re2 record
à rollers je pense qu'il nous faut ce
type de défis parfois un peu farfelu
parfois un petit peu fou ne serait-ce
que pour en parler pour parler de sport
il a réussi à le faire post confinement
donc ça c'est déjà une très bonne chose
brest reste à voir aussi à discuter
peut-être avec lui quelles sont quelles
sont ses motivations au départ mais je
trouve ça assez frais de pouvoir faire
ça il vous lavant se faire plaisir et
tenter quelque chose d'insolite
et bien bravo m bravo à lui alors thomas
dirais que nous présente justement les
dangers d'une tête traversée en roller
c'est dangereux
oui dans les descentes en fait quand
roller on prend plus de place qu'en vélo
sur une route parce qu'on fait un
balayage avec les pieds et ça ça fait
que les voitures ont plus facilement
nous frôler elles vont aussi moins faire
attention à nous parce qu'elle ne
considère pas comme un véhicule
contrairement à vélo et du coup on n'est
plus en danger vis-à-vis des véhicules
aussi du dénivelé et c'est plus physique
donc on peut être plus facilement
fatigués fait chuter la question sur ce
tales cet exploit était plus fort que sa
traversée du désert de sel en bolivie
oui ou non vous était est-ce que c'est
plus fort ou pas non oui à ont fait un
petit duel entre ea les gens et grégory
alors gens c'est à vous vous commencez
jeter quoi la question cet exploit et
s'il plus fort que sa traversée du
désert de sel en bolivie l'année
dernière
non c'est pas plus fort pour moi parce
que voilà là on serait on est en et sur
les performances physiques qui est
impressionnante c'est vrai mais je dis
ça parce que pour moi a tracé du désert
c'était plus dangereux il y avait
beaucoup plus de d'alger notamment et
qu'il était tout seul sans assistance
c'est vraiment arrêter vos épaules c est
donc dans quelques uns beaucoup plus de
risques de danger que ceux traversés en
rollers donc c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
ce n'est pas ce qu'il dit par contre
dans son dans sa vidéo mais c'est normal
c'est normal qu'ils disent que ça parce
que lui et c soit dernier tout qu'il a
fait et puis l'a vu à part les aléas
grégory et règles pour que les gorilles
réseau il ya du beau jeu vidéo ça pour
gagner le combo off mais avait dû
corriger ses propos moi je suis plutôt
d'accord vous êtes d'accord avec jean
d'accord pour dire excusez moi j'ai voté
dès demain jeudi je dis si je suis un
assez d'accord avec le dernier argument
de gens et je trouve qu'en termes
d'exposition d'exposition et notamment
la notamment pour les vacances pas de
confinement tournée rester en france
tout le monde est parti en france et là
c'est là aussi traversé la france donc
je pense que sur l'exposition et
peut-être aussi sur le la pratique du
roller qui est peut-être qui est
peut-être un petit peu plus plus répandu
en france c'est la plus plus plus fort
en termes d'exposition médiatique en
terme de danger il yad'un côté dans un
désert et des orientations des airs de
celle ci notamment la désorientation les
températures oui c'était avec une seule
navette le prêt ça c'est assez bas et ça
avait duré six jours
voilà c'est balèze est pour le coup
après c'est un effort plus il était tout
seul bien sûr c'est un effort plus longs
en roller il l'a rappelé les dangers sur
la route sont la russie à ses nombreux
notamment avec les voitures qui frôle
donc s'il faut comparer je dis que c'est
c'est un petit peu plus fort dans la
durée dans l'effort et dans l'exposition
médiatique après vraiment sur le point
de vue que moi je suis vraiment d'accord
avec jean sur le côté mais qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué de traverser le
désert de sel que traverser la france en
roller après si on prend sur le point de
vue social juste après une crise
sanitaire on y est toujours mais d'aller
faire ce tour de france 3 qui dormait
chez l'habitant h à salle terme et chez
les amis proches avec un vrai défi à se
lancer pour ça moi je crois qu'il a il
ya plus à la balade un pékin express un
petit sms et je pense que c'était aussi
plutôt difficile mais on
petit avait peut-être besoin si d'aller
à la rencontre de ces gens et personnes
ont pu l'accueillir ça je trouve que
c'est un défi réussi deux points de vues
rapprochées la nuit chez le maire de
lyon s'écrie alors comme comme vous le
savez moi j'ai pratiqué le roller de
vitesse pendant pendant quelques saisons
j'ai été champion de france
il vous simplement comment c'est beau ça
mais pas d'europe par contre non non non
je n'ai fait que je suis champion du
monde de cyclisme aussie est maintenant
tu ne sont plus que champion d'europe
mais avait donc voilà je ce type
d'effort en rollers mois traverser la
france en presque deux mois c'est ça
c'est ça de moi il est parti exactement
alors il est parti le 18 juin dernier il
est arrivé le 25 août
ouais du coeur alors je pense qu'il a dû
je pense qu'il a dû faire comme ça pour
traverser la france parce que du nord au
sud jeudi les parties de l'île il
arrivait la frontière espagnole
du nord au sud oui mais il n'a pas dû
faire comme ça il a dû faire l'impasse
que la gg il hallucine la dystonie
blague il a dit brodeur l'a dit j'ai
souvenir en rollers d'avoir fait des
randonnées de 160 180 kilomètres j'ai
fait j'ai un pari pour le téléthon et et
on a fait ça dans la journée donc on
était sur des sur des raids de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres par par jour et
donc lille lille lille et la frontière
la frontière espagnole
c'est quelque chose qui peut se faire en
une dizaine de jours au grand maximum
donc c'est vrai je trouve que
je trouve pas que ce soit un exploit
formidable ce type de ce type de choses
et en effet je pense que les six jours
et six joueurs étaient beaucoup plus
intensifs dans le désert dans le désert
sans assistance voilà pour moi pour moi
il n'y a rien de rien d'extraordinaire à
aller faire deux mois de roller et
maintenant c'est par contre c'est génial
parce que en effet c'est une discipline
qui est trop méconnu et et qu'on puisse
en parler aujourd'hui eh ben je trouve
ça très bien parce que c'est
c'est un sport qui c'est un sport
complet et c'est un sport qui est aussi
une très belle école de école de la vie
parce que parce que ça demande
énormément de d'implication pour pouvoir
briller à un haut niveau et
malheureusement les sportifs durant
l'heure ne sont pas assez assez reconnus
comme les pistards dans le cyclisme
alors il voudrait maintenant relier la
france à dakar en auto stop
vous pensez que c'est possible ils
voudraient parti en décembre et vous
laisse pensif en décembre six parfums
descendre et qui n'attend qu'à esso
change l'itinéraire du rallye
paris-dakar et peut-être le faire
rapidement des moins quinze jours ça
peut être réglé mon bateau stop
peut-être j'ai pas être toutes les
précisions mais voilà ils vont aller
relier paris à dakar du coup en
auto-stop point de vue légal c'est sans
argent peut-être également les pays qui
sont fermés avec les français qui sont
pas forcément les bienvenus en ce moment
partout dans le monde
on verra bien grégory scie alors bravo
comme vous voulez j'en lis les mains
attachées dans le dos les yeux bandés
alors encore encore un grand bravo quand
même à thomas d'eric pour son sa
traversée si on passe maintenant notre
page découverte
[Musique]
on passe à notre thématique sur la
découverte on va parler de body karaté
qu'est ce que c'est grégory le body
karaté c'est un mélange entre le karaté
et la danse c'est de savoir en lice la
pratique est né en france au début des
années 2000 alors là on voit des images
au club de rambouillet qui est l'un des
seuls dans les yvelines à pratiquer
cette discipline il a été créé pour un
public voulant pratiquer un sport de
combat sans contact violent
c'est un art sans contact je les dis à
rambouillet vous avez l'opportunité en
plus de le pratiquer avec une championne
puisqu'elle a été multi championne de
france de karaté c'est véronique mesnil
de vido c'est un sport je le précise qui
est en tout cas pour le moment aux
pratiques et à une grande majorité par
des femmes 90% mais elles restent quand
même accessible à tous on écoute les
responsables de cette activité aux robes
houllier sports karaté le body karaté
c'est des enchaînements de karaté fait
sur de la musique ce qui permet de
travailler notamment le cardio toutes
les chaînes musculaires et évidemment
dans une bonne ambiance
il yad'abord l'échauffement la partie
body karaté et vers la fin on fait un
petit peu de renforcement musculaire
la question sur ce thème et ce coup
vous aimez ce sport ce que vous avez
envie de le découvrir oui ou non non
pour vous et yann genre qui est très
indécise on va faire un petit chemin
entre grégory et pierre clatot pierre
vacances et moi j'ai toujours un peu de
mal avec c'est avec ces sports qui
essaye de se mixer entre eux donc à
l'hybride j'ai du mal avec les sports
avec jet pack jugé jusqu'à ne pas aimer
mais j'ai du mal à ça c'est sûr c'est
sport hybride notamment il peut y avoir
le football s'il peut y avoir le body
combat on en a vu d'autres avec les
sirènes qui les sirènes en apnée c'est
alors le l'esprit humain est extrêmement
inventif et extrêmement créatif
lorsqu'il s'agit de de créer des
nouvelles disciplines
on peut on peut parler là pour le
body karaté de sport parce qu'il ya une
vraie dépenses fixé comme du du body
combat où le ou la zumba
donc là il ya une vraie dépense physique
après lier ces deux sports je me demande
quel quel est l'intérêt au départ il ya
déjà pas mal de sport de gymnastique de
fitness de crossfit qui existe là qui
sont vraiment sur le sur le culte du
corps sur le cardio et sur la et sur
l'entretien l'entretien physique et qui
permet notamment à tous les âges de
faire des sports et ça ça c'est une
c'est une très bonne chose
je ne vous je ne vois pas tout de suite
l'intérêt de mixer 2000 ces deux sports
ça pourrait être aussi du jeu du body
judo par exemple pourquoi pas mais donc
j'ai du mal sur le principe de base
après en considérant tous permet à tous
à tous les âges de faire du sport
pourquoi pas mais il n'en sera rien je
me tend une perche moi je trouve que oui
c'est intéressant de pouvoir mélanger
ces deux sports karaté danse pour ouvrir
au plus grand nombre on sait que ça peut
freiner certaines personnes de pratiquer
ce genre de sport ce qu'il ya des
contacts forcément et en plus le karaté
je trouve que c'est intéressant mais
tous les arts martiaux je pense que s'y
prête
il ya des mouvements des mouvements qui
sont intéressants au niveau de la danse
ou voilà il ya beaucoup de dépense
physique donc je ne connais pas encore
assez le body karaté mais ça me donne
envie de pourquoi pas de le découvrir un
peu plus jean vous qui êtes un
spécialiste des mouvements dans peu
orthodoxes artistique artistique qu'est
ce qu'ils en pensaient alors moi moi je
rejouais je rejouais pierre je rejouais
pierre la catégorie x est accessible à
tous
j'ai regardé quand même 8 fait des
images la plupart turcs haut niveau au
niveau cardio c'est accessible à tout le
monde mais bien parce que c'est ni plus
ni moins une bonne science de strech et
le cardio de monte carasso donc
simplement voilà moi je dis pourquoi pas
avant alosi le premier parce que faire
du sport là dessus ça pour ça mais après
quand elle body karaté ou en lambert et
bientôt gênant mais là mais bientôt
baume et au jeu mardi pour autant que tu
veux après lui à commencer à saturer
alors je préfère revenir mais mais bon
c'est pour moi aller le jeu retient que
le que l'effort physique et le sport
mais sinon pour moi ça près de monterrey
diagne gériez à mieux gérer les
changements et des frontières je vous
voyais pas bougé vous connaissez mon
amour pour pour les sports bizarre voilà
je maintenant là c'est vrai que l'on
peut considérer ça comme on peut
vraiment considérer ça comme un sport
parce qu'en effet il ya une vraie
dépendance est un vrai on est on est on
est très loin des devises fortes
mais ouais il ya un moment où c'est bon
on avisera zumba c'est un truc pour les
filles se faire à chanter j'ai surtout
dit non parce que j'aime pas les sports
de combat en général
donc pourquoi apprendre un sport de
combat si c'est pas pour porter des
coups au final quoi là je comprends
encore moins là encore moins le principe
donc non je n'en je valide pas gérer
même pas faire une séance
contrairement à jean qui nous a toujours
promis l édition comprenant la belote la
body de l'auto le jour de l'arrivée 2
alors on va terminer par une note de
musique c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission le rappeur atik a tourné un
clip de rap avec son ami colo avec
l'équipe de football américain des
templiers d'elancourt
mais qui atik grégory si vous êtes fans
de la série validé vous l'avez forcément
découvert dans ce rôle d'appât ce jeune
rappeur qui monte un peu dans le rap
game voilà c'est le terme que l'on
utilise vous les avez perdu et ruraux
cette série de franck gastambide qui a
eu un grand grand succès en france elle
a été notamment diffusé pendant le
confinement alors atik de son vrai
prénom clément clément p noah il a 27
ans il est originaire et de guyancourt
du quartier des garennes
il a notamment donc je les dis été
révélée dans cette série validée même si
dans l'industrie musicale il existe
depuis quelques mois il ya notamment son
projet et chaises pliantes alors le
principe c'est tout simple il prenait sa
chaise pliante il aller dans les
quartiers l'installer pour aller rapper
avec des rappeurs voilà de ses quartiers
ce projet il y avait notamment le titre
angela pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
une remise de saïan supa moi oui et à
une reprise de ces mêmes supa crew tout
à fait à l'été certifie chance à
certifier c'est ça on va regarder
justement al extrait du clip d'atik avec
les templiers
[Musique]
tu veux une nouvelle baisse
quand je rentre alors bonjour vous qui
êtes un fan de booba et des mines m
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais écoute
n'est égoutter j'aime me fait mal
comparaissent à eminem je ne les bons
bords les mines m
[Rires]
alors pourquoi ce que je trouve super
bien voilà c'est l'idée de mixer donc
toute une culture musicale et non est
justement de 2,2 de cette culture
musicale de faire parler d'eux de son
quartier et devient dès lors passer le
club local le club local qui est quand
même à en deuxième division de football
américain est toujours sous les eaux ils
sont pas remontés je crois pas jarrier
je suis obligé de vous
cette émission je suis désolé alors
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission a
terminé comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de bruce lee qui en plus d'être
un acteur était un champion des arts
martiaux cmx voilà on peut faire les
deux ans yann alors celui qui veut
réussir doit apprendre à combattre
persévérer et souffrir je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]